[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy ponemos la vista atrás y hacemos
un balance de estos tres años desde que
Reino Unido abandonó la Unión Europea
qué ha pasado desde entonces antes de
pasar al debate Luisa Pulido
corresponsal de Londres de France 24 nos
hace un repaso sobre lo que ha ocurrido
durante este tiempo entre Reino Unido y
la Unión Europea el brexit que sigue
dividiendo a la población ha significado
casi que un terremoto para este país y
que abrió la puerta para la
inestabilidad política con cuatro
primeros ministros desde entonces ha
habido escasez de alimentos frescos se
han incrementado los precios de estos ha
habido aumento de la burocracia y de
nuevos trámites para importadores y
exportadores algunos de esos factores
han jalonado la inflación que azota al
Reino Unido según el London School of
economics el brexit obligó en sus
primeros dos años a que un lugar
británico comentar a sus gastos en 210
libras esterlinas unos 260 dólares
además que el divorcio con la Unión
Europea abrió heridas que se creían
sanadas como el deseo de Escocia por
independizarse del Reino Unido Y
actualmente Londres y Bruselas
renegocian el protocolo de Irlanda del
Norte que creó una frontera nueva una
frontera comercial en el mar de Irlanda
se espera que estos cambios este nuevo
acuerdo esté listo antes de abril para
la conmemoración de los 25 años del
acuerdo de paz de 1998 del que Estados
Unidos es garante pero para ello Londres
y Bruselas requieren más que buena
voluntad y para analizar estos tres años
desde que se produjo el brexit tenemos a
los eurodiputados y más Rodríguez Piñero
del grupo socialdemócrata bienvenida
Inma Hola Muchísimas gracias encantada
de estar aquí placer y con Antonio López
istúriz del partido popular europeo
bienvenida Antonio Muchas gracias muchas
gracias a los dos empezamos primero
viendo que ya vemos muy palpables las
consecuencias del brexit muchas cosas de
las que se prometió en campaña no se han
cumplido y da la sensación que el país
no tiene un rumbo claro el brexit se ha
llevado por delante a cuatro primeros
ministros en los últimos años fue el
brexit un error de cálculo de Reino
Unido y más Bueno yo creo que fue un
error no sólo de cálculo fue un error
desde la base como se planteó Cómo se
engañó a la ciudadanía primero
advirtiendo de los males que era estar
en la Unión Europea sobre todo una serie
de datos y de informaciones
absolutamente falsas no y por otra parte
prometiendo lo que era imposible que se
iba a conseguir por parte de la Unión
Europea que advertimos decimos muchas
resoluciones y tuvimos mucha ocasión de
hablar con diferentes representantes de
la sociedad civil y de los grupos
políticos británicos advirtiendo todo lo
que está cuando era previsible yo creo
que ha sido el triunfo desde luego de la
demagogia del populismo y de la de la
desinformación y aprovecharse una
situación de descontento creyendo
ofreciendo una alternativa que era
absolutamente inviable y el tiempo no
estaba dando la razón Antonio un error
de cálculo de las dos partes
la británica la conocemos sobradamente y
los resultados los estamos viendo ahora
no con la crisis económica la huelga
general que ha habido hace poco en el
Reino Unido en fin lo estamos viendo
cada día no por nuestra parte nos
confiamos demasiado creíamos que estamos
ante una negociación más de estas que
estábamos habituados con el Reino Unido
tira y afloja y tal y cual yo recuerdo
personalmente algunas conversaciones con
David Cameron Aquellos tiempos y él nos
garantizó que el referendo me iba a
salir Por supuesto que iba a ser
positivo y bueno nos lo creímos y pasó
lo que pasó error de juicio los
referéndum son así cuidado también es un
sí o un no
y se prestan hoy en día mucho en este
mundo donde están los populismos
campantes Yo creo que el brexit fue
cuando realmente todos caímos en la
cuenta y la posibilidad de la
desinformación y de los fake news que
estuvieron a la orden del día con
potencias extranjeras interviniendo y
hemos aprendido por nuestra parte muchas
lecciones de esos días
el gobierno conservador británico parece
que no ha aprendido ninguno pero el
pueblo británico las está aprendiendo
por la vía dura
en fin vamos a ver si hay algún cambio
en el futuro y puede haber un gobierno
no sé si habrá una vuelta a la Unión
Europea pero por lo menos una relación
mucho más fluida que es lo que toca al
hilo de lo que comentas Antonio menos de
un tercio de los británicos piensa ahora
que el brexit fue una mala decisión
según una encuesta reciente y una de las
cuestiones durante la campaña fue
justamente la migración y ahora el país
sufre un déficit de mano de obra fue el
brexit consecuencia de la globalización
y de la polarización que también vimos
por ejemplo con la elección de Donald
Trump lo acaba de comentar
indudablemente
más que Trump vuelvo a insistir
fue la desinformación generalizada los
brexiteros se nutrieron Y estuvieron
apoyados por grupos de interés de muchos
países que no querían que esta Unión
Europea saliese adelante que son los
mismos de siempre es decir no les gusta
que estemos unidos porque somos un
problema para ellos decir Bueno pues ya
digo que afortunadamente por lo menos
nosotros en nuestro caso ya hemos
aprendido esas lecciones durante la
Guerra Ucrania se está demostrando el
sistema de lucha contra la
desinformación a las que no tenían
habituados los rusos pues está
funcionando yo creo que eso es
importante
otra de las consecuencias del brexit es
la es lo que ocurre en Irlanda del Norte
para evitar una frontera física que
dividiera la isla de Irlanda se hacen
controles en el mar Pero según Londres
Esto no es efectivo y ahora se están
renegociando algunas de las partidas de
este protocolo de Irlanda del Norte hay
un peligro real de que vuelva la
violencia No yo eso sí que no lo creo
porque para que vuelva la violencia
tiene que haber un interés en que vuelva
la violencia y el objetivo de todos es
que no vuelva a la violencia No lo que
pasa es que Reino Unido jugó muy mal sus
cartas Porque todo lo que está pasando
insisto también el protocolo de Irlanda
del Norte se advirtió cuando era la
solución lo que se le ofreció al Reino
Unido era formar parte de la unión
aduanera y no quiso porque su objetivo
era dejar las reglas de la Unión Europea
y de acuerdo con sus prioridades
ganar su libertad No regulatoria pero
claro eso tiene las consecuencias la
libertad regulatoria lo que da lugar es
a que tienes reglas distintas tienes
barreras administrativas Yo he estado en
Irlanda del Norte hace muy poco y real
estuvimos reuniones con todos los
representantes de toda la sociedad civil
de la clase empresarial la clase
trabajadora todos los representantes de
asociaciones de consumidores etcétera
grupos políticos por supuesto y están
todos descontentos con las trabas
administrativas que hay y piden una
solución pero es que la solución no
puede ser que el Reino Unido niegue la
realidad que tienen y haya Renegado de
un acuerdo que acababan de firmar y
habían aceptado y que han pretendido
romper todas las reglas del juego de los
acuerdos internacionales entonces
realmente Reino Unido ha jugado muy mal
las consecuencias estoy de acuerdo con
lo que decía tono las está pagando el
pueblo ciudadano en la situación
económica es catastrófica hemos conocido
hoy que el fondo monetario emocional ha
dicho que Reino Unido es la única
economía de las grandes países
industrializados que decrece y que no es
capaz de recuperar todavía el producto
interior bruto que tenía antes de la
pandemia
inflación altísima
desempleo
desesperanza realmente no saben manejar
su libertad porque están en una
situación infinitamente peor lo mires
por donde lo mires en el Reino Unido
pero respondiendo de nuevo a la pregunta
yo no creo que se vaya a producir una
una resurgimiento de la violencia la
guerra en Ucrania ha cohesionado mucho
más a la Unión Europea de lo que se
esperaba en un principio justamente este
mensaje de que es estar mejor Unidos
ante la adversidad es lo que permite que
otros países igual vean que mejor no
seguir el mismo camino de Reino Unido
Bueno yo creo que es el principio todos
los países lo vieron clarísimo había
algún entusiasta incluso nuestro país
que a raíz del brexit decía que bueno
que a lo mejor sería una buena idea y
tal No esos estos que siempre están en
contra la Unión Europea y bueno la
realidad pues la realidad como se dice
en inglés realityvites la realidad final
te come
la unidad de los europeos hay que
entender que en la historia
Reino Unido utilizó mucho la división
entre los europeos en su propio
beneficio a veces también a beneficio
nuestro durante la Segunda Guerra
Mundial pero la división continental era
estrategia de supervivencia el Reino
Unido y lo fue durante cinco siglos
Cuál es la primera vez que falla esa
estrategia durante la durante el brexit
durante las negociaciones posteriores
también intentaron por tierra mar y aire
dividir a los países europeos y no lo
lograron tuvimos la unidad detrás de
Michelle nuestro negociador jefe que fue
una negociación impecable transparente
cuando la suya no lo fue en absoluto Y
por cierto desde el minuto menos la
preocupación por Irlanda del Norte que
compartíamos todos los grupos políticos
y una fuerte unidad europea ideológica
territorial en apoyo de nuestros amigos
y como y compañeros irlandeses para la
mejor solución no podemos decir lo mismo
del equipo británico Pero
afortunadamente la cuestión está por
ahora calmada y estoy seguro que la
Unión Europea continuará siempre
apoyando para evitar que haya ese
momento de violencia
un 40% de los británicos cree que se
debería celebrar un nuevo referéndum
Aunque entramos un poco en el territorio
de la especulación es posible que Reino
Unido vuelva a entrar en la Unión
Europea y más yo no sé si a largo plazo
eso es posible a corto medio plazo yo lo
veo imposible además
los referéndum son blanco negro y yo me
parece que eso es una barbaridad decidir
grandes decisiones valga la redundancia
que afectan a un país a una sociedad a
la ciudadanía con un referéndum que
nadie tiene en la capacidad de hacer la
pedagogía necesaria para dar a conocer
las consecuencias de las decisiones que
se tomen en un referéndum Me parece que
no se debería repetir ese tipo de
ejercicios no pero bueno según los
analistas británicos ellos creen que
puede que en 10 años haya un ciclo nuevo
y se pueda plantear ese debate hoy por
yo creo que no es posible Lo que sí es
posible y se debe de conseguir es que el
Reino Unido establezca unas condiciones
que permitan un diálogo y una un
perfeccionamiento de aquellas cosas que
podemos mejorar ambos lados En beneficio
de una relación es que deben de ser
fiables y que deben garantizar una
prosperidad la Unión Europea lo estamos
haciendo bien pero verdaderamente Reino
Unido tiene que hacer un análisis
crítico constructivo para mejorar el
Reino Unido
y salió de la Unión Europea pero no de
Europa y
yo creo sinceramente que nos unen
tenemos lazos económicos de seguridad
financieros de todo tipo que harán que
con un gobierno tal vez más razonable en
el próximo futuro podamos yo creo que
establecer las vías para que
Reino Unido tenga una relación Europea
nosotros sería el deseo de mucho de
nosotros estoy convencido no sé hablo Es
decir que el Reino Unido formase parte
de nuevo esta Unión Europea tardará
mucho en pasar pero bueno Yo creo que
las circunstancias mejorarán el camino
entre ambas partes perfecto nosotros lo
tenemos que dejar aquí Gracias Inma
Antonio a ustedes les esperamos en el
próximo programa de Europa hoy
[Música]